des fûts à perte de vue nous sommes à la
money a rivière pilote est le maître des
lieux c'est lui daniel baudin 20 ans
déjà qu'elle exerce son art c'est le
maître de chai du groupe bbs belloni
bourdillon et successeur est déjà elle
prépare la relève avec son assistant le
nail bar elle s'est très végétal donc
n'a pas encore pris les notes de boisés
le groupe a reçu six médailles d'or pour
ces roms lors du salon de l'agriculture
des récompenses qui viennent saluer le
travail de daniel bodart en véritable
chimiste c'est lui qui détermine tout le
processus d'assemblage de création et de
production en maître de chai c'est comme
maître d'école donc il a à élever des
enfants à éduquer des enfants donc le
maître de chai va éduquer ces roms en
faisant le choix de son fût de ces fut
le choix de son de ça chauffe et de ces
assemblages donc c'est comme comme un
professeur qui va faire un élève arriver
au meilleur de son potentiel
on va mettre le chef c'est un tout c'est
quelqu'un qui va fédérer ses équipes
puisqu'il n'est pas tout seul et à le
préparateur il ya d'autres personnes qui
vont l'aider à faire ses assemblages
autre lieu autre producteur à avoir reçu
des médailles
hs l'habitation saint-etienne depuis
2002 lionel blampain en est le maître de
chai et c'est sous son impulsion que la
marque a développé de nouvelles gammes
alors là je suis en train de prélever
un vieux en cours de préparation donc je
vais procéder à l'analyse sensorielle
bulot là nous avons les notes fruitées
alors vous avez agrumes
[Musique]
puis les bois
ce qui fait la caractéristique du rhum à
chasseuse c'est la technique de
vieillissement
nous avons fait le choix de travailler à
partir de fils neuf donc
des fûts en chêne américain type bourbon
que l'on achète 9 qui viennent
directement des états unis avec 47
médailles dont deux en or
les robes martiniquais ont une nouvelle
fois montré ils sont des produits
d'excellence